welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 the finale
to James Gunn's guardians of galaxy Saga
in a true Heartbreaker for lovers of
animals and proper skin care I am gonna
break down this full film scene by scene
for all the visual details Marvel Easter
eggs deeper layers of meaning that you
might have missed and I will say you
will appreciate this even more if you
check out my Guardians re-watch analyzes
on the Deep dive Channel including in
today's volume 3 live stream q a and you
can support the new rockstars network
with a Guardians inspired shirt design
like this 89p13 rocket science shirt or
one of our many other Guardians designs
over at nerdriot.shop the film opens
with a Guardians of the Galaxy themed
version of the Marvel Studios title card
with moments and script lines from
across their seven appearances in the
MCU prior to this 2014's Guardians of
the Galaxy 2017's Guardians Volume 2
Avengers Infinity war end game Thor 11
Thunder I am Groot and the Guardians
holiday special the quotes include
drax's Volume 2 line about dancers vs
non-dancers his symbolic Journey gets
paid off at the end of this movie and
Rockets line for volume 1 ain't nothing
like me except me a uniqueness that we
will explore in this opening scene but
the first image in yellow on the Marvel
text is rocket cry in the moment Groot
we are grooted and the last before the
images swipe away are the guardian's
first team of shot in the Kiln in volume
one from this we fade in on a cage of
screaming raccoons now these kits were
designed by VFX company frame store and
they are so playful you could see the
smiles on their faces until the door
opens and their ears fold down all you
fellow dog owners out there know that
when the ears fall down like that it
means the animal is triggered also a big
No-No the high evolutionary reaches in
with his palm facing down which they
always advise against because it's a
threatening gesture you should always
reach out with your palm facing up all
the other kits cower away leaving 89p13
alone front and center to be grabbed why
didn't rocket hide with them though
maybe bravery maybe he just wanted to
spare the other kids or maybe there's
something unique about his brain that
makes him more defiant in the face of
this kind of Cruelty there's a really
cool effect where we pushed in on
Rocket's nose and the fur warps into a
different head shape and the trailer is
just a cross dissolve but in the film it
shows how Rocket's skull was physically
reshaped by Windham surgeries this cruel
experimentation on Rocket was alluded to
in the past films the implant scar is
still visible on his back in the Kiln
his drunken rant why did it has to get
made I didn't have to be torn apart and
put back together over and over and
turned into some
some little monster rocket no one's
calling you a monster in volume two
yondu's line I know them scientists what
made you never gave a rat's ass about
you I'm serious dude which was
interesting because it shows that yondu
knew who Herbert Windham was he wasn't
some man of the Shadows he was out proud
and publicly doing this to creatures
around the Galaxy there's also this
subtle line in Avengers end game he's
pissed he thinks he failed which of
course he did but you know there's a lot
of that going around ain't there
honestly into this exact second I
thought you were Build-A-Bear maybe I am
rocket has until now not known exactly
what species he is only denying that he
was a raccoon because of its negative
connotation whenever someone called him
that but this movie clears it up and
it's interesting how life builds a bear
they do go back to the manufacturer so
we transitioned to present day rocket on
nowhere remember nowhere is the separate
head of a Celestial introduced in volume
one and Revisited an Infinity war and as
of the holiday special the new home of
the Guardians and all the refugees after
thanos's conflicts we hear an acoustic
version of radiohead's creep played from
the Zune this zoon was was passed on to
Peter Quill from yondu via cragland at
the end of volume 2 to replace Peter
Quill's Walkman and mixtape that was
crushed by ego this soon contains music
from all decades all the way through the
2000s so this soundtrack has some modern
music on it creep came out in 1992 and
it has been sampled and used again and
again most notably in the Swedish girls
choir cover of the social network
trailer music this song is the anthem of
the Lonely Outcast but we have to note
that radiohead's Tom York told Rolling
Stone that he thought his lyrics were
pretty crap so it's really a song about
self-hatred and hating yourself for
hating yourself James Gunn always writes
his tracklist into his scripts and he
plays the music on set to inspire the
actors and justifies the music Source in
the context of the scene to make it
diegetic so the songs aren't just
randomly playing over everything but
really they're a choice a character made
to play and to listen to Rocket shows
this acoustic version of creep to feel
especially mopey about the all-time
mopius song Rocket passes mantis and
Drax mantis tries to get Drax to dance
and he says only idiots dance this
cosmack Jax's line volume two there are
two types of beings in the universe
those who dance and those who do not
which inspired my long-running MCU
theory that all Marvel characters are
either dancers or non-dancers and
dancers are the team players while the
non-dancers might need the Multiverse or
some other kind of love connection to
find a dance partner but eventually
everyone in the universe is going to
join in some kind of Dance For Better or
Worse nebula pins up a neon sign written
in the cree language that translates to
Guardians of the Galaxy which close many
of the trailers for this movie helping
her is swole Groot now remember Groot
beefed up in the guardian special to
show him being in an early 20 College
jock stage of his development having a
different Anatomy than the volume 1
adult Groot because that Groot was
technically this group's father they are
not clones of each other Groot is a
species called Flora Colossus they feed
on what's called photonic knowledge
that's gained from light sources and
since Groot has been in the company of
beings like quill and mantis who are
descended from a Celestial I have
theorized that he might have absorbed
their Celestial light and he grew more
this way it was confirmed of the
Guardians holiday special that mantis is
is indeed a child of ego making her
Peter's half-sibling explaining why one
of ego's mates in that movie was the
same race as mantis part of a deleted
scene in which we would have met
mantis's mother nebula has a new
nanotech weave arm gun confirmed that
this is made for her by rocket to thank
her for gifting him Bucky's detached
vibranium arm from the holiday special
which we still have no idea how she got
rocket continues to listen to the song
all the way into this bar on nowhere
where Peter's drunk we saw him moping in
here in the holiday special he's still
depressed it for Gamora he's got issues
rocket sips a strength from a container
marks in Creed letters that translate to
milky something Peter passes out and all
the Guardians join nebula as she carries
him back to bed something that sounds
like they have to do all the time and
when she tucks him in he grabs her arm
and says I love you Gamora which is
really gonna sting nebula since Gamora
was always the preferred one when it
came to thanos's affections the who
knows the way Peter looks at nebula
later in this movie there might be
something there undirected by James Gunn
the lights switch out in Peter's bedroom
a way of showing James Gunn putting this
trilogy to bed now in an exterior
establishing shot nowhere is established
with new coordinates now these kind of
location coordinates from all three
movies have been confirmed to contain
James Gunn's long lost Easter egg but
it's gonna take us some time to decode
the ones in this movie especially since
we haven't fully decoded the ones the
past two films but trust me we will
break this down in a future video once
we do it's gonna be a very big deal when
this Easter egg is finally decoded now
remember in volume 1 the coordinates
were M3 Rd
17h17211 plus two one two one two two
four which the online code breaker
Community translated to Meredith quill X
or something related to that but nowhere
now being different coordinates tells us
that this skull is now mobile pilotable
battleship with giant jet engines on the
back setting up the big twist in the
third act in the meantime if you want to
try decoding these yourself the
coordinates are for nowhere it's now
m211
r516xs16c plus 1615 1mw counter Earth is
K20 hmw 1748 p2s plus 5m5p 0 Z4 and for
orgocorp a41p p23 26y 430 plus
174144v rocket tests out chekhov's
gravity boots I'm calling them because
he says he's testing to see if they work
upside down on slope surfaces freely
setting up the later use of these in the
film in the Oracle Corp exterior they
all snack on roasted orlonies on sticks
orlonies are the rat creatures that we
see scurrying around all these movies
craglin is back played by Sean Gunn who
does the physical performance of rocket
in all these movies James Gunn's brother
he's got yondu Spin and arrow that he
gained at the end of volume 2 but he's
struggling to command the arrow maybe
because he's focusing too much on the
whistle and not enough on the heart
power connection that yondu said is
really needed to direct this arrow and
that could be why the arrow plunges
right into where nebula's Heart Like
Cupid's arrow but she does not find love
in this movie Paris and craglin is Cosmo
the space dog returning from the holiday
special and before that the collector's
vault in volume one she is telekinetic
and voiced by Maria bakalova Cosmo in
the comics is based on the tragic story
of Leica the Russian dog who's set in
the space by the Soviet Union on a test
mission and never returned home like the
animal in this movie cruelly sacrificed
in the name of science rocket reminds us
of mantis's empathic abilities asking
her to cheer Peter up saying why don't
you just touch him and make him happy
and Groot asks I am Groot and they all
gag and say no not like that gun has
said that in the past that many of
groot's I am groots translate to f-bombs
and filthy phrases and then Adam Warlock
flies through space set to Hearts Crazy
on You Adam was incubated naisha's
golden cocoon in the volume 2 post
credit scene the bolt in his head is a
nod to the comics version of the
character who carried the soul gem one
of the infinity gems Infinity Stones in
his head as he plays a major role in The
Infinity Gauntlet storyline but the MCU
kind of reassigned that detailed to
Vision in a way with a mind Stone I
would say Vision has been to the MCU
along with Doctor Strange what Adam
Warlock does in the comics like in the
comics he's not really a doltish mama's
boy he's more like space Jesus
engineered by a group of scientists
called The Enclave and renamed from him
to warlock by the high evolutionary but
James gun's a point with all these
movies is to expose the Folly of
supposed genetic superiority and how how
it really leads to bigger monsters than
the monsters are now crazy on you is
actually playing on Rocket soon as he
digs up this device we later realize
this is the key card that he rigged to
free himself the others of batch 89
showing that he has never let go of that
mission to free anyone else on that ship
Adam Warlock tackles and grabs a dazed
rocket who uses those gravity boots to
slip out of his grasp the cree letters
in Orange neon next to him translate to
UK Adam says but if you go squirrel yeah
part of the running joke of these movies
of everyone calling rocket different
mammals your Associates sir welcome even
that triangle-faced monkey there you're
leaving me with that fox he's not a fox
the rabbit is correct and clearly the
smartest among you nebula confronts Adam
[Music]
on the ground round her hover pose and
her arm shifted into a glowing Blaster
makes her look a lot like Iron Man when
he initially tried to detain Loki in the
2012 Avengers nebula even amplifies her
voice with a loudspeaker function and it
kind of sounds like we hear the Stark
Repulsor warm-up sound effect during
these scenes who knows rocket may have
built upon his nanotech after seeing the
Stark Tech during his time on Earth and
end game Adam punches nebula in the jaw
dislocating it this is the same jaw
dislocation that nebula snapped back
into place when she was fighting Gamora
in volume 1. he tosses her into that
orloni stand and she knocks them
everywhere Groot pounces on Adam and he
Coons him in his branches but since Adam
is accustomed to busting out of cocoons
this doesn't last long group gets
beheaded but luckily later Sprouts
branched legs out of his head looking
like the spider head form of the alien
shapeshifter and John Carpenter's The
Thing starring Peter's dad ego they're
able to repel Adam but this attack on
rocket leaves him mortally wounded with
the others unable to use a med pack due
to a cybernetic kill switch installed by
Windham who considered Rocket's Parts
proprietary technology so on death's
door rocket flashes back to windham's
initial operation a close-up Rocket's
eye his trembling restrained body with
tubes and needles you can actually see
his paws shaking in the shot remember
his and our booking screen volume 1
showed quote cybernetic skeletal
structure enhanced phalange and
metacarpal bones and genetically
augmented cerebral cortex which means
they augmented his paws to give him
opposable thumbs and they made him smart
enough to know what they are doing to
him we see a close-up of 89 p13 tattooed
to his chest remember this was a
numerical code that rocket had in the
first film and now we know that he was
part of batch 89 that also included
89q12 AKA Lila who was also listed as an
associate on that booking screen meaning
either rocket told others about her over
the years but since quill says that
rocket doesn't talk about his past that
much more likely scenarios that Windham
told other authorities rocket might
bring her up which is also pretty effed
up of him so rocket meets these others
of batch 89 in the cage Lila is an otter
creature voiced by Linda Cardellini who
also plays Lauren Barton in the MCU but
was a past collaborator with James Gunn
and the Scooby-Doo films in the movie
Super Lila of course is right Pockets
past love in the comics but here it
really just seems like they're really
really good friends and never builds
beyond that Chiefs The Walrus is voiced
by Asam chaudry he tells rocket you got
a mask out of your face in volume 2
there is a painting of rockets animal
colleague wall Russ appearing on that
wall of the brothel and contraxia behind
gandu Michaela Hoover voices floor the
rabbit and albino with red eyes who
speaks through a voice box and has these
robotic spider legs reminding us of the
initially creepy baby face to Toy Story
but is really just the sweetest of the
bunch and Rocket's first spoken word is
hurts kid rocket is voiced by Noah
Raskin but they comfort him and Rocket
later remembers playing tag with the
batch 89 and laughing so by remembering
these he's already making peace with
passing on meanwhile the Rockets are
heading to orgocorp to save him after
Tony Stark calls him a Build-A-Bear they
are essentially going back to the
manufacturer for the directions we hear
rainbows since you begun that we heard
in the trailers and they are piloting
their new ship the Bowie in volume 1 and
volume 2 the ship was the Milano named
after Alyssa Milano that ship wrecked in
volume 2 so an Infinity war and end game
the new ship was the Benetar named after
Pat Benatar this new largest ship is
named after David Bowie of course whose
song moonage Daydream played when they
first arrived to Nowhere in volume 2.
Aisha and Adam meet with Herbert Wyndham
on his base on counter Earth now in the
comics the high evolutionary Herbert
Wyndham is Marvel's Ultimate geneticist
initially introduced in Thor comics in
1966 and he played a role in the 2008
Annihilation Conquest storyline that
these Guardians films are partly based
on he's known for creating Animal Human
hybrids like the anime men or the new
men and having a fortress on Mount
wundergore where Pietro and Wanda
maximos spent some time as babies here
he's played by jakuruji whom gun just
worked with last year on HBO's
Peacemaker counter Earth in the comics
is a synthetic version of Earth created
by the high evolutionary and placed a
micro second out of dimensional sync in
order to hide it from Earth but here
it's just an artificial copy of Earth
built in physical space and the comics
is populated by the new men but in this
movie it is a similar race of windham's
evolved animals from batch 90 and Beyond
we learned that wind himself created The
Sovereign as quote an aesthetic
experiment calling them quote beautiful
numbskulls but your egos have run wild
this is why the Sovereign when we met
them in volume 2 or their Planet didn't
have any bases in Marvel Comics they
were original Creations by gun because
gun always intended them to be products
of a higher power their obsession with
genetic design inherited by the high
evolutionaries genetic superiority and
their oddly artificial planetary chain
really a construct the way counter Earth
is also interesting that the abolisks
FED on the sovereign's anilax batteries
or if your Drax harvelary batteries and
generally terrorize The Sovereign when
Wyndham also has on his ship obelisks
suggesting that they were also his
Creations just shows that Windham trying
to play God and create his own Animal
Kingdom results in these species
devouring each other he's no better than
the celestials are at creating peaceful
balanced biodiversity Windham says Adam
was meant to be the war Rock the apogee
of their people in the comics is the
high evolutionary who renames him this
Bean's Divine name from The Enclave and
renaming him Adam Warlock but Aisha
blames Windham for taking Adam out of
the Cocoon too early and I love the
design of windham's stretched out face
tissue how it's pulled over this
metallic clip on his temple in the
flashbacks that same metal clip is on
the outside of his skin so right away we
know that his present day face is really
a mask covering something horrible
underneath that happened in the time
between the Guardians arrive at orgo
Corp orgo meaning organic or carbon
based as this is windham's Corporate
front for the cybernetic parts and
implants used around the Galaxy the fact
that yondu knew scientists made rocket
tells us this galaxy knows who Windham
is it just looks the other way when it
comes to his experiments on Lower life
forms nebula points out how this
facility is bioformed instead of being
built it's composed of living matter
this structure is fleshy and it has a
thick yellow fluid running through it
inside you see the yellow fluid running
through hoses and pouring down fountains
this could be the same fluid as the
obelisk's yellow blood especially since
Windom made them both and it could even
be the same yellow fluid derived from
the celestial spinal tissue on nowhere
the drag splashed into this movie
doesn't explicitly link all of this but
they all look like the same thing and it
wouldn't make sense for win him to try
to evolve life forms using Goo then he
pulls out of the corpses of the Gods of
the cosmos they fly the Bowie through
these plasma Shields and mantis reminds
Peter that he has family back on Earth
his grandfather Jason who made a cameo
back in Missouri in volume 2 setting up
the Indian scene of this movie now Peter
falsely remembers that his grandfather
quote screamed in my face and pushed me
out of the room which is not true at all
Grandpa was the one who put Meredith's
present in his backpack for him and
tried to keep him from running away and
Peter says you know what's sad people on
Earth die when they're like 50. are you
about to die I'm not 50 and if you look
closely at Drax when mantis asks if
Peter's about to die at age 50 drags
nods also he's eating czarg nuts in this
scene this is a snack food that he ate
very slowly in Infinity War to show his
ability to become invisible you you're
eating a zorgnut
for my movement
was so slow
but it's imperceptible
Peter's red shirt and all these scenes
has an orloni on it maybe this is a
shirt he got from that roasted orlony
stand on nowhere and nebula's contact
arrives the ravagers led by Sylvester
Stallone returning next to car oh Gorge
from Volume 2 also returning as Krueger
who opens Dr Strange style slingering
portals he is a Lem species a sorcerer
in the comics he's actually sorcerer
Supreme from Earth 691 an alternate 31st
Century reality his ravager badge on his
chest has a green gem on it which he
might use as his own eye of agamoto now
of course it wouldn't be the time Stone
the time Stone was atomized in this
universe remember there's also martinex
once again played by Michael Rosenbaum
and Mainframe who's previously voiced by
Miley Cyrus but is now voiced by Tara
Strong who voices Miss minutes in the
TBA and Loki we learned Gamora has
joined these ravagers remember this is
the ultimate 2014 Gamora from Avengers
end game who turned against Thanos but
since winter owned separate way from the
Guardians because she has no memories
with Peter in the other Guardians of the
Galaxy she and nebula just give each
other this wordless nod which I love it
is just how these sisters communicate
throughout this movie the orbital core
of jumpsuits at the change into have
this interesting logo that looks like an
X but kind of like a flayed man evoking
both the Vitruvian man of Leonardo da
Vinci but also poor rocket when he was
splayed during his operation rocket
flashes back to another memory with
Windham when he completed complex
equations on the Blackboard and seeing
counter Earth as window points to the
blue sky and a rocket inspiring 89 p13's
chosen name and at this point slightly
older rocket is now voiced by Bradley
Cooper again Windham explains that the
chance they are listening to are a
recording quote over 5 000 years old
translated to pinotes you are but as you
should be this would suggest that
Windham has access to sound recordings
from 3000 BC now the languages folks
sounded like Latin but ancient Rome was
not that old so this must be another
older civilization like the cree or the
zandarians or hey maybe even the
eternals whatever the source sound
recordings from 5 000 years prior sound
like something Windham could have gotten
via connection to a time traveler like
Kang the Conqueror his telekinetic
purple armor seems to operate similarly
to Kang's suit in quantumania Windham
shows rocket his plan for batch 90 a
chamber with Mists that can guide any
organism through millions of years of
evolution in an instant demonstrating
this on a turtle who becomes something
like a pissed off Teenage Ninja Turtle
and immediately goes violent due to the
overproduction of a certain kind of
protein now it is not labeled as such
but this process looks a lot like Terra
Genesis a process in the Marvel World in
which terrigen mist is inhaled and
causes the creature to mutate into a
super-powered inhuman in the comics
that's how Kamala Khan gets her powers
though in the MCU she's a mutant not an
inhuman young Rocket says they can't be
peaceful but Windham corrects him [__]
with a proper British accent which also
sounds like he's calling rocket
something awful but also perhaps
referencing the philosopher Emmanuel
Kant who founded the ethical principle
that an action can only be moral if a it
is motivated by a sense of Duty and B
its Maxim may be rationally willed a
universal objective law Wyndham believes
he is following kantian ethics to
rebuild the world to free it from
violence even if his methods to achieve
that are cruel rocket observes the
problem with the filter causing the side
effects something Windham didn't see
proving to Wyndham that rocket possesses
a brain uniquely capable of invention
although all of windham's Creations went
through this kind of cruel
experimentation only Rockets succeeded
this way which could just be a random
coincidence or might suggest that rocket
has some unique genetic condition the
way Peter Quill from his mother
Meredith's jeans was the only one of the
ego's progeny to carry the celestial
Gene well the MCU nut up and label this
mutation maybe in 2026 space hogs in the
meantime plays as the Guardians float
down toward Oregon in these colorful
spacesuits which look like the Among Us
suits but are actually references to the
spacesuits in 2001 A Space Odyssey
according to James Gunn nebula saws into
the flesh wall spewing up this yellow
blood and Peter tries to confess his
love to Gamora but she shuts them down
and the others chime in Peter you know
this is an open line right what we're
listening to everything you're saying
and it is painful and you're just
telling me now we were hoping it would
stop on its own but I switched it over
to private what color button did you
push blue for the blue suit oh no blue
was the Open Line for everyone orange is
for blue what black is for orange yeah
calories for green green is for red and
red is for yellow no yellow is for
yellow green is for red red is for green
I don't think so try it then
you're right only yellow is the correct
color meaning only Peter would hear it
when they actually want to yell at him
green is for red red is for green Drax
wears a red suit here in the comics he
is the color green but back in the first
film James Gunn changed him to the color
gray with red tattoos because he said
the MCU already had enough green skin
characters they create this airlock seal
in the flesh wall setting up the same
technology to be used as the airlock
seal between Wyndham ship and nowhere in
act 3. they are found by Master karja
played by Nathan Fillion who came out in
volume 1 as a blue skinned alien
prisoner in the Kiln and Cameo did in a
deleted scene for volume 2 as Wonder Man
Simon Williams in various movie posters
in Missouri the Oregon corpse security
monitor is a cameo by Jennifer Holland
who plays Amelia Harcourt in DC Universe
and yes is James Gunn's wife and people
get weirdly triggered when Gunn puts her
in stuff almost like they are looking
for any possible reason to be mad at
James Gunn these days even though he has
always put his friends and family and
everything he makes like all directors
do for example the orgacorp worker they
force to help them is Europe played by
Daniella melchior who played red catcher
2 in James Gunn's The Suicide Squad now
your time with the Guardians of the
galley Galaxy doesn't have to end with
the conclusion of the film Trilogy
Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy is a
single player story-driven
action-adventure game out now for
PlayStation and Xbox consoles and PC
you've probably heard some great things
about this game it won best narrative at
the game awards 2021 the game features
an all-new story set in an original
Universe these characters are inspired
by both the comic Guardians and the film
Guardians so they feel fresh and
familiar at the same time it's a fun and
epic story but it also has the heart and
deep character arcs that we love about
these films play as Star-Lord and lead a
guardian's team of Drax Gamora Rocket
and Groot there are appearances by
mantis Cosmo and Adam Warlock they all
feel like living breathing characters so
you get to experience something really
unique and being their leader calling
the shots and trying to bring those
strong personalities together there's a
great soundtrack of course with both an
epic orchestral score and some classic
80s jams they made an original Rock
album just for the game the game
includes many outfits for the Guardians
inspired by the comics and the MCU
including suits inspired by the 2008
Guardians of the Galaxy Comics just like
in volume three continue your guardian's
journey with Marvel's Guardians of the
Galaxy on Playstation Xbox and steam the
others sneak through oracord where a
video clip proclaimed that orgacorp has
been producing cybernetic implants for
the Galaxy for 300 years meaning that
Windham has been active since at least
the 18th century another clue that he
might be aligned with Kang it has access
to multiple periods of time Gamora
nebula Peter and Yura access the
archives to find 89 p13's file meanwhile
they argue whoever it was that you were
in love with it sounds more like her
hers do not bring me into them
knock it out get out what
notice how black your eyes were they
were replaced by my father as a method
of torture he he picked a pretty set
nebula reminds us that she too was
cobbled together with spare parts as a
form of torture by her father Thanos
which is why I think she and Rocket make
great leaders in this group by the end
of this film because they are of all
these characters the most broken they
take the elevator back up and Peter
Recaps Infinity war in in-game press we
used to be in love yeah she was my
girlfriend only she doesn't remember it
because it wasn't her because her dad
threw her off a magic cliff and she died
and then I lost my temper and nearly
destroyed half the universe
and she came back out of the past there
she is
everyone else who died in the past
stayed dead not her why was it the magic
Cliff I don't know that's some freaking
infinity stone scientist
and some dumbass Earth dude who met a
girl fell in love
that girl died
and then came back a total dick
that is the just
ice like how Peter owns up to his part
and punching Thanos out of that trance
when they nearly got that Infinity
Gauntlet off his hand but to be fair to
Peter Quill it wasn't solely his fault
that Thanos won a lot of people made a
lot of mistakes also Thanos was just a
badass he's gonna find one way or
another also this whole scene does feel
like James Gunn's meta commentary on the
MCU taking his characters and killing
one of them off in other movies
complicated his plan for them but I love
how Peter tosses that eight nine p13
sphere like a baseball Chris Brandt did
the same thing with the orb in the 2014
film and dropped it a take that they
left in the film we see in this section
how a younger gamora's less empathetic
approach as a child of Thanos as she
threatens everyone and shoots Jennifer
Holland in the leg while Peter prefers a
less violent approach promising era he's
just gonna speak to the Oracle centuries
from his heart but really he's just
lying to her to get into the system to
make their suits float he starts by
using his heart and ends up using the
kind of clever move that rocket would
with his brain because rocket did
essentially the same thing in the Kiln
in volume three causing all the guards
to float so they can get out of there
meanwhile rocket remembers the memory
where they all pick their names
Someday I'm gonna make great machines
that fly
and me and my friends are gonna go
flying together
into the forever and beautiful sky
Lila
tips
and floor
and me
rocket
rocket remember rocket got that name
from Cena rocket soaring over counter
Earth his dream was never to live on
counter Earth it was to escape it and be
an adventurer and while he dreams of
going flying into the forever and
beautiful sky with these three this also
applies to what he ends up doing with
his other friends as he snaps at Peter
in volume two I was cybernetically
engineered the pilot of spacecraft
remember there was also that random
memory Peter recalled of jet packing
into the forever and beautiful sky with
rocket and Baby Groot so rocket
definitely achieved his dreams just with
another family and poor poor thieves his
eyelids are literally motorized by
mechanical Parts meaning the poor guy
cannot even blink naturally every time
we see these guys my heart breaks nebula
explains the high evolutionaries
considered a God in corners of the
universe using orgacorp to fund his
experiments outside of Intergalactic law
which is what Roman day was referring to
back in volume one eight nine p13 calls
itself rocket the result of illegal
genetic and cybernetic experiments on a
lower life form nebula says that Windham
created zoronians anime and Sovereign
Sovereign Aisha's people any men we've
talked about but zironians are the pale
skin humanoids with plates that cover
their mouths seen beside the collector
in the Thor of the Dark World
post-credits scene and see in the
background of all the Guardians titles
but in the comics zironians are a
peaceful race who can gain powers from
solar radiation karja and Aisha catch
one of the ravagers outside Oracle Corp
and they use Adam to interrogate him but
he fries our
melted
melted if on cigar and Thor Ragnarok out
of Morlock feels bad about blurp being
left behind so these two team up blurp
is a fur-covered fasaki confirmed by
James Gunn to be the same species that
all the people bet on in the bar on
nowhere in volume 1. when it was
fighting the orloni Peter listens to The
Flaming Lips do you realize on a Zune as
they float through space it drags talks
to Peter about metaphors saying I know
lots of analogies quill analogies
metaphors etc for instance gamora's head
is like a lily pad because it is green
metaphor
calling back drax's ongoing struggle
with metaphors from the first film yeah
I'll have to agree with The Walking
thesaurus on that one do not ever call
me at thesaurus it's just a metaphor
dude his people are completely literal
metaphors are gonna go over his head
nothing goes over my head my reflexes
are too fast I would catch it then on to
another flashback wind and drunkenly
demands B13 to tell him how he knew
about the protein issue and demonstrates
that he figured it out evolving a
kangaroo and a monkey into humanoid
forms he says batch 89 was never going
to counter Earth saying you can figure
out the complex workings of cytoplasmic
filtration systems but you couldn't
figure out that poor rocket he's a
genius when it comes to technical stuff
but he's just too trusting and that's
not his fault that's Windows fault for
giving him this brain and giving him two
loving of a heart winning orders to keep
rocket for studying and for the rest of
batch 89 incinerator and then on to
counter Earth Faith No Morris We Care a
Lot plays as they arrived at this planet
which is interesting just like Earth
they got polar ice caps like Earth does
nebula says the gravity is xandar minus
one comparing gravity to that of the
planet xandar Capital the Nova Corps and
as they approach a city there's a
doppelganger for Liberty Island in the
Statue of Liberty but with Herbert
Windham holding a monkey his way of
making himself the savior in the Open
Arms greeter for all these animal
hybrids they land the Bowie right in the
middle of the suburb and they realize
that wouldn't have designed it to
replace American Suburbia in the 1980s
the exact era and setting that Peter
left behind this girl bounces the
Kickball to Drax and he immediately pegs
her with it
that sound effect it's just so specific
we all know that sting I'm gonna get the
face during dodgeball these suburbanites
rage and Groot gets pegged in the face
of the rock so he grows into this
stretched out monstrous form and he wags
his tongue to scare them looks like he
is using a chunk of bark as a tongue
these were telling his own Ambitions to
grow into Alpha Groot where he would be
a show or no-grower in the post-credit
scene inside this counter Earth home we
hear this wild song that's called koinu
No Carnival from minute waltz by a
hammock
so this is produced by a voice
synthesizer software called Vocaloid
there are over 5
figures that are represented here
including what sounds like Cosmo howling
at one point
it is so cool that they had this awesome
song in here in the detail throughout
this house is just so good the family
portraits and the growing pain style
setup yadro figurines it looks like even
this kind of busy World Richard's scary
wallpaper that shows a bird sitting on a
swing and a mouse walking past a fence
Peter uses the woman's car but he and
nebula struggle to open the door push it
down I am pushing down on it push the
button
it looks like you're pushing the keyhole
the what there's a button under the
handle press that in
okay now what open the door ah so this
of course was uncensored in the movie
but it is the mcu's first official
uncensored F-bomb all the others we've
heard so far have been censored like
Senator Stern and Iron Man 2 thank you
Mr Stark Cube buddy or cell censored via
editing or some other form like Nick
Fury when he dusted in the infinity War
post credit scene
or the running gag in the Spider-Man
films where the what the [__] get cut
off
that's right folks James Gunn said that
you can only get away with one F-bomb in
a PG-13 movie and he's generally right
he said that Chris Pratt improvised it
and they left it in the MPAA
restrictions on these things are really
weird and subjective but usually they
prefer it if you're gonna try to put an
F-bomb in a PG-13 movie if it's gonna
happen at all to occur at least an hour
into the movie and this one hits at an
hour and 10 minutes in as Peter tries to
drive the car since he was a kid when he
left Earth he's terrible at it street
sign conscious new drivers about
pedestrians has animal heads instead of
normal round human heads Gamora
drunkenly goes through Peter's backpack
that he left Earth with finding a
Polaroid photo of Peter with his mother
Meredith and grandfather Jason in one of
Peter's elf cards we saw some ALF
stickers on the tape deck on the Milano
in the first film out of comics are
technically Marvel Canon like Alf shows
up in The Infinity Gauntlet storyline
and one of these Comics showed up in I
am Groot during this section we hear
Alice Coopers I'm always Chasing
Rainbows Peter nebula and Groot drive
through the slums of counter Earth and
we see a drug deal going wrong an
octopus head dealing with some cockroach
heads the deal apparently played by Dane
Robert D ligro A basketball player to an
actor who played the predator and prey
Windham Broods while the test subject
phyla runs in a ring around him like the
jogging sequence in 2001 A Space Odyssey
Windham says these kids survive on 30
calories a day and an hour of sleep a
week and he plans for these to populate
one of his upcoming colonies phyla is
played by Kaizen and returns to the
post-credits scene the MC version of
Phila Vel who becomes Quasar in the
annihilation Conquest storyline the
artificially created daughter of the
cree Marvel and companion to drax's
daughter moon dragon based on her
glowing eye in that post-credit scene it
looks like her powers are going to be
rooted in the same kind of Cree Cosmic
radiation source as Monica Rambo Kamala
Khan and Carol Danvers and then the
final flashback Rocket returns to the
batch 89 cage to free the others
enjoying one big hug from Lila who
repeats it really is good to have friend
and then Glam shot in the back by
Windham by hugging rocket she served as
his human shield perhaps the most
disturbing thing about the scene is how
Windham wails mockingly back at Rocket
like in Silence of the Lambs when the
Senator's daughter screams in the well
and Buffalo Bill just scream he's back
at her all creepy and rage rocket
Sprints to Windham and Claws at his face
and Windham fires back at him missing
rocket but as Rocket realizes later
those blasts hit thiefs and floor and so
back in the present we get our first
look at women from the side where we see
that his face is really just his skin
tugged and bolted in to the side of his
head the reason he looks this way is
because rocket left him this way and
Windham chats with Peter I visited your
planet many years ago Earth hasn't been
my planet in a long time if people had
wonderful spirit the art and music and
literature with some of the finests in
the universe Earth
would be a fabulous place for it not for
the ignorance and bigotry okay it
inspired me to create counter-up I don't
care all of the good and none of the bad
I
tint whack job whose mother didn't love
him rationalizing why he needs to
conquer the universe yes another meta
line poor Peter after hearing villains
like ego and Thanos explain their evil
plans and why they weren't evil but
Justified Peter's just had enough of it
it's interesting note that Wyndham says
he visited Earth but he doesn't consider
it his home world so where did he come
from it's also kind of cool how Earth's
culture is admired throughout the
Universe just explains how in the
Guardians movies the people of nowhere
have started to embrace things like
Christmas and rock music just something
special about Earth Peter points out how
windham's counter Earth Society ain't
perfect and on a dime window's like yeah
and he just nukes the planet and he
launches home after home in this suburb
explode in its red geometric ship Rises
cracking this bridge the speed to which
windham's willing to do this and
threaten to do this Daisha makes it seem
like Wyndham has dumped other test
planets before I mean Thanos most likely
wrapped up a higher body count and Kang
has definitely killed trillions in
alternate timelines but Windham having
been alive for 300 years must rank up
there among the most murderous Marvel
villains and seeing its neighborhood
explodes this makes it so sad that we
spent so much time in that neighborhood
with that nice family and their awesome
blue soda they're really cool music
they're awesome wallpaper just countless
families and children all slaughtered
and this includes Aisha who dies so fast
in that blast that Adam Warlock and we
have barely any time to register it
Groot and Peter get in the shootout with
windham's men and Peter tackles teal out
the window Groot Dives after them and he
latches on to Peter midfall kind of like
the Mark 7 suit and the 2012 Avengers
catching Tony mid dive and Groot extends
its branches to form bird wings and
allows Peter to fall with style they
crash land they kill teal and Peter
prized the 89 p13 schematics out of
Teal's head and it catches the ride with
Gamora on the Bowie off this Doom Planet
meanwhile nebula drags the Mantis hop on
a Windham ship and nearly freeze in
space setting up the threat of Peter
freezing in the vacuum of space in the
Final Act Peter Gamora and Groot rushed
to bypass Rocket's kill switch but
rocket slips into this limbo realm
that's really just an Overexposed
version of their batch 89 cage room on
Windham ship which is pretty tragic
because it means rocket never really
escaped it mentally despite the other
saying they fly around rocket is stuck
in this room and they come back to
initially bring them to the afterlife
but either way this crossroads right
here is the one place that these four
souls ever shared now this is yet
another take on the afterlife in the MCU
after the ancestral plane the Black
Panther mythology the duat and Moon
Knight Valhalla and Thor love and
thunder the soul realm of infinity War
like all of those it's somewhat abstract
and arguably a reflection of the nearly
departed subconscious but it's
interesting in this scenario that it's
not the dyer who chooses to return to
life it's the forces Beyond who keep him
there Lila stops rocket and says not yet
that he still has a purpose so is this
rocket telling himself that he has a
purpose or some other Cosmic Force the
same force that Peter Quill witnessed
when he grabbed the power stone look to
Gamora and saw his mother on her
deathbed Lyla says there are the hands
that made us and then there are the
hands that guide the hands she's saying
that Windham created rocket for his own
reasons but beyond Wyndham was a higher
power who blessed rocket with a unique
brain beyond anything Windham could
comprehend and that brain not what
Windham did is what makes Rockets
special and I think that higher power is
totally connected to Meredith quill
Peter's moment in that first film and
the moment Peter flashed back to his
memories with his mother Meredith and
all the others in the moment he was
fighting ego in volume 2 and Fleetwood
Max to chain played I think this quote
from Lila is also why rocket chooses to
spare Wyndham later yes because he's a
freaking Guardian of the Galaxy but also
rocket wants to be the hands that guide
the hands feeling the higher calling as
Frankenstein's monster to forgive The
Sinner and follow a more enlightened
path Lila says my beloved raccoon this
story has been yours all along you just
didn't know it as James Gunn has said
rocket has been the secret protagonist
of the entire Guardians of the Galaxy
Trilogy and as Rocket tries to correct
her saying I'm not a raccoon he's yanked
back into Consciousness as he's still in
denial for now quill and Groot hug
rocket it's in swole group can't get
close enough because of his big bulky
soldiers and pecs he snakes and more
branches to draw Rocket even closer to
him so the two factions the Guardians
connect via radio mantis asks how they
got off the ship Groot chimes in a Groot
and from those three words mantis is
able to have that they jumped off the
ship and Groot turned his body into a
parachute so not only are they all
getting better at interpreting groot's
vocalizations mantis as an empath is
just more sensitive at picking up the
subtext between the words nebula breaks
down a relief upon hearing that rocket
is okay remember while all the other
Guardians were dusted rocket and Gamora
were the only two of them left behind
and those two spent five years together
so they have a much stronger friendship
than most of the others do also during
that time rocket War Peter Quill's Red
Scarf to remember him what is this a
Taylor Swift lyric I swear this is the
tightest group of friends in the MCU I'm
gonna miss him so much smack on nowhere
Cosmo joins the others playing cards
much like the famous dogs playing poker
painting at the table is Cracklin Howard
the Duck coming back once again Boys by
Seth Green and it came here by Lloyd
Kaufman James Gunn's Mentor from his
days with trauma entertainment who
actually played a prisoner at the Kiln
in volume one and then that xandar
antiques dealer from volume 1 played by
Christopher Fairbank who had a great
role on Andor and share the screen for
this iconic moment
you
I'm Batman Cosmo telekinetically
levitates her cards while telling her
tragic Soviet backstory pretty much the
same story as like the space dog in real
life saying 1966 the Soviets put me on
the rocket knowing full well I could
never return and would die in a fiery
ball of death but still to her that's
not as bad as cragland calling her a bad
dog so the Guardians approached
windham's ship and the Bowie detaches
into a gunship in Two fighters it's
really though a flank maneuver is on the
other side craglin Pilots the entire
freaking skull of nowhere to fire upon
Windham ship Windham screams kill
everyone on the head of that dead God
they use a Celestial skull as a pirate
ship to haunt Wyndham in such awesome
symbolism because Windham considers
himself a new God improving on the
designs of the celestials the dead Gods
when really he's no more successful than
they were later he screams that recorder
Vim there's no God that's why I stepped
in yes in James Gunn's archetypal Battle
of Gods versus Monsters the gods are
those who claim to be Gods always lose
Windham desperately activates the hell
spawn the soldiers meant as an army to
protect the New Colony hulking cyber
genetic animal hybrid drones and
warriors who look so freaky they invade
nowhere Craigslist to concentrate to
activate the yaka arrow and he briefly
envisions yondu Michael Ricker returns
to tell craglin to use his heart boy
just as he told Peter while fighting the
ego in volume 2. it's not controlled
with the whistle or with mind it's with
the heart Jack's mantis and nebula run
into avalisks mantis is able to tame
them reminding us that they don't eat
people they eat batteries even when Drax
was inside it it didn't digest him it
has a strict diet of any lacks batteries
or if your Jack's Harvey Larry batteries
the other is pilot into Windham shuttle
Bay out of Warlock and blurb board
Gamora and Quill's gunship and quill
sets it to self-destruct so they end up
with blurp in their arms blurp by the
way in this movie is voiced by D Bradley
Baker who does most of the voices
including the clone troopers in Star
Wars Clone Wars a very talented man and
speaking of VoiceOver actors War Pig was
voiced by Judy Greer who plays Scott
Lang's ex-wife Maggie it turns out all
the Avengers spouses in the MCU are
doing vocal cameos in this movie Peter
plays The Beastie Boys No Sleep till
Brooklyn which was also referenced to
Spider-Man no way home No Sleep Till
Boston
Beastie Boys are having a bit of a
moment in Marvel right now with
Intergalactic and the recent trailer for
the Marvels but then set to this music
we get a full two minute unbroken long
take of the Guardians slaying their way
through this hallway it's a true
celebration of teamwork every five
seconds there's a cool new detail the
way they work together like we stay with
groot's branches initially as he
punctures through the hell spawn one of
them down the guy's throat as the group
grows more and more branches to poke
through his body mantis swings from this
same Branch like a gymnast beam and
lands on a guy's shoulders flipping him
back into that same Branch then rocket
shoots a health spawn lands on groot's
shoulders calling back that image in the
Kiln in the 2014 film he runs along this
branch and the gamer follows him as he
jumps and shoots downward and then
through the hole in one of the hell
spawns bodies that he just shot then we
focus on Peter Quill as he works his way
down the hallway attaching taser nodes
to three different guys and then just
waits to activate them until they're all
running back at him in nebula nebula
gets her neck dislocated and her head
just dangles down her back as she
continues to fight and we end the fight
with Gamora using her God Slayer sword
to sever that octopus captain in half
and blur pops on the midsection stump so
cool mantis freeze one of the hybrids
I was screaming at something scary
behind you not you you look really cool
thank you well this guy is named lamb
shank and I Diggy's Voice by James Gunn
Rocket returns to his old cage looking
inside and seeing a dozen more other
kits just like him and he uses the same
key card to free them on the door he
reads the label luminous Wildlife Center
ter 3211 9021 I would say these could be
terrorist coordinates but the
coordinates were different in the
Captain Marvel film the Marvel's trailer
so I'm not really sure origin North
America kingdom and Amalia phylum
Cordata that refers to animals with
backbones and then we skip order class
family and get to genus species
prescient LaTour common name raccoon
which established his rocket as a
trueborn North American raccoon and he
came from Earth just like Peter Quill
did Windham interrupts tossing them
calling him
and eight nine P one three and the way
Uzi shouts this code it sounds just like
Javert and Les Miserables shouting two
four six zero one rocket really has been
his Jean Valjean his lifelong Pursuit
and Javert is destined to fail because
I'm pretty sure when Russell Crowe fell
into that Fountain he landed on his face
Kimora delivers on Quill's recurring
promises that this would be a Face-Off
and he peels off windham's face mask
revealing that gooey disfigured face
underneath from how rocket left him in
this moment totally evokes Red Skull in
the first Captain America film a
character who's technically still alive
and space in the MCU and both villains
come from the same philosophy of genetic
superiority Peter runs back for a zoo
just like how he refused to leave the
Kiln without his Walkman and his mixtape
in volume one he said there's himself
but cuts the cord to space Glide
something he has done before when he
rescued Gamora and in that scene they
pointed out that gamora's cybernetic
implants enabled her to survive in space
for just a few minutes implants that
Peter also has actually maybe thanks to
Herbert Windows Orca Corp now they think
of it but he gets caught in debris and
Peter starts to freeze and bloat Adam
luck redeems himself touching Peter's
finger recreating Michelangelo's
creation of Adam as this really is the
creation of Adam as a member of the
Guardians of the Galaxy and he scoots
pop a potato back into nowhere Gamora
joins the ravagers Peter tells the
Guardians that he's leaving as does
mantis and Drax wants to leave with
mantis but nebula says you weren't born
to be a destroyer you were born to be a
dad not Drax the Destroyer Drax the dad
quill picks rocket to lead that
Guardians and they salute him with a
ravager salute I love the scene because
they're all in the circle all of them
standing except rocket just like that
moment on the ravager's ship before the
final battle in the first film when
rocket was the last one to stand bunch
of jackasses standing in a circle and
Groot says I love you guys the first
time we heard him say anything other
than I am Groot or we are Groot but I
like to think we the audience are in the
heads of the Guardians in this moment we
are hearing what they are hearing
because after nine years and seven
titles before this finally our ears have
adjusted to the vocal variances of
groot's voice and we can understand him
we finally are Groot rocket sits beside
two of the raccoon kits that he's saying
with a note from Peter written on the
corner of an elf print I went back and
got this for you knowing how big a fan
James Gunn is a Britney Spears he didn't
name his old dog after her is this not
an oops I Did It Again reference well
baby I went down and got it for you oh
you shouldn't have
a little Wrong song instead he Scrolls
to the 2000s playlist and plays Florence
the machines the dog days are over and
everyone warms up to it because as
Windham said there is just something
about the Arts and Music of Earth Groot
dances again we saw him rocking out in
the Guardians holiday special rocket
joins him Peter meanwhile returns to
Missouri and his grandfather Jason quill
the origin of Peter's middle name Jason
and Greg Henry Once Again plays Jason as
he did in the 2014 film and in cameo in
volume 2. post-credits scene Jason's
newspaper includes reference to Kevin
Bacon's abduction in the holiday special
and a shout out to James Gunn's dog Lola
and back on nowhere the dance party
rages it draws in Drax who previously
insisted that he was not a dancer but
the kids get to him and we see the new
Guardians lineup including Rocket and
Groot who will soon be Alpha Groot or
King Groot with that Crown head in the
post-credit scene as well as craglin
Cosmo blurp Adam Warlock and phylavel
the journey of the series has to bring a
bunch of Misfits together in a dance
battle to save the universe and that
battle has finally been won please
subscribe to the Deep dive Channel also
our official third channel in the new
rockstars Network the break room it's
getting its own channel this is gonna be
the new home of future break room
episodes and where all of our after
shows and reaction videos will live we
actually have a few great videos coming
out throughout May so head on over to
subscribe to the break room right now
for new content and official launch in
June also if you live in the LA area new
rockstars will be live at the lyric
Hyperion theater on Friday May 26th at 6
PM we got tickets both live and person
and tickets to a live broadcast of it if
you live somewhere else both will be
available in the links below you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA
boss follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
thank you
[Music]